a lot of people fear solitude yet the
great psychiatrist Wincott said that the
capacity for solitude is one of the
greatest markers of psychological health
so if you can develop your capacity for
solitude that means that you are okay
being alone with your self as Cal
Newport who wrote the book deep work
notes some of the most meaningful things
in our life we do in our life that add
unique value to the world that are not
replicable as he puts it are operate
under the conditions that are complete
distraction-free where we try to
eliminate as much as possible oh that
that ringing you know for our phone that
we have new text or we have a new email
and or looking going Facebook and
checking like so disconnecting from the
outside world as much as possible and
get in a situation where we're in
complete solitude that we can get
completely immersed in and really follow
through to completion something in a
very deep way he argues that is very
conducive to a good life as well as a
meaningful life it doesn't mean that if
you developed your capacity for solitude
that you're a misanthrope is what I want
to say doesn't mean that that's a false
dichotomy you can develop your capacity
fully for optimal deep work but but you
can also develop your capacity to
collaborate with others so that once you
come up with ideas or generates things
that are deep you can then share and get
feedback and then go back it's a
constant process constant cyclical
process where you go back and forth
between getting feedback from the world
and seeing what your sense of audience
is very important to know what your
sense of audience get a sense of your
audience when you're producing a
creative work but it's also very
important to have moments where you go
into solitude and you and you embrace
and embrace the the beauty of silence
you